- What proof do you have
that the earth is flat?
- With my own eyes, I have seen distances
where we shouldn't have
been able to see objects.
- If you were alone in a
room with a flat earther,
what would you ask?
- How would one prove
that the earth is flat?
- Why would NASA and these scientists
lie to us about it?
- Yes, that is like the
million dollar question.
- Hello, I'm Pamela.
Nice to meet you.
- Hi, I'm Shelley, nice to meet you.
- Did someone convince you
that the earth is flat?
- Well, I wouldn't say
that someone actually convinced
me the earth was flat.
- So why would NASA and these scientists
lie to us about to us about it?
- Yes, that is like the
million dollar question.
I think that they're doing
it to maybe protect us
from something that
they think is out there
that they don't want us to know.
I have my hypothesis is that I think
that they're hiding the
true creation of this earth.
- How do you think the earth was created?
- I believe the Bible when it talks
about the earth was created in seven days,
he created a firmament
and he created the sun
and the moon and the stars
inside of the firmament.
- What I guess proof do you
have that the earth is flat?
- With my own eyes, I
have seen distances where
we shouldn't have been
able to see objects.
- Could you describe
the shape of the earth,
like a piece of paper or a plate?
- The best way I can describe
it is it's like a circle
like a clock with a
dome over the top of it.
- So where do you believe
the earth ends then?
If you believe it's flat, like
where is the fall off point?
- It could be like an infinite plane.
The Bible says it can't be measured.
I know that's not
scientific, but you know,
that's just kind of what
we've experienced as well.
Even going back to what Elon
Musk had said at one point
not that I believe
everything Elon Musk says,
but it was interesting and intriguing
to me of what he said was that we live
in a simulation.
- There's a one in billions chance
that this is based reality.
- How many people would
I guess be in on it?
- Very few people, high
up people are in the know.
- How do you feel about the pictures
of the earth from space?
- If you look at those
pictures, NASA will even admit
that their CGI and even a
gentlemen from NASA said
that some of the pictures that they get
from satellites are these composite images
that they have to kind of paste together.
And so it's hard for me to say
with all certainty that
those pictures are authentic.
- Do you think the moon landing was fake?
- Yes.
- What led you to believe that?
- So my husband actually
brought home this movie talking
about how the moon landing was fake
and I honestly was like so upset
that he would even go there with me.
I started to question it more.
Sure enough, there's absolutely no way
that they could have gone to the moon.
Absolutely.
- Honestly, I agree.
- Oh, you do?
- I do agree yes.
Tell me what you think.
- Just the way it was depicted.
It really never connected in my mind.
- I was not expecting you.
- Yeah.
that's cool.
- How do you explain like
the phases of the moon?
- We believe that the
moon is its own light.
A lot of people think
that the sun basically
reflects onto the moon,
but what we find is that the
moonlight is a cooler light
and the sun is more of a hot light.
- So if the earth is flat,
how do you explain time zones?
- So if it's a close sun,
it would be kind of like a spotlight.
The time zones work
because that local light
just kind of like a flashlight,
doesn't light up the whole circle
it only lights up a
certain part of the circle.
- I'm curious what the explanation is
for gravity and things
like the coriolis effect.
- Well, gravity's still
technically a theory.
We know that there's an up and a down.
As far as coriolis,
I was in the military
and I've shot weapons
and we were never once taught
to account for coriolis.
- What kind of weapons,
if you don't mind me asking, like ICBMs?
- Well, when I was in the
military we shot M16's
and okay the rail gun is a question
because it can shoot a hundred miles
and it's a line of sight weapon.
So a hundred miles using
the curvature of the earth,
it just doesn't make sense
that they'd be able to hit the target.
- With the the globe model,
it's like 24,000 miles the circumference?
- Yeah, like 25 we kind of used, yeah.
- Yeah, okay.
So 100 miles would be
less than 1% of that.
So I guess it's not much of a difference.
Like it doesn't matter as much.
I guess I'm asking more in
relation to things like rockets
like ICBMs or airliners
and stuff like that.
- Airliners, if they were flying,
let's say a thousand miles,
they would have to dip their nose down
to stay in a line with the globe.
- So do you believe in global warming?
- So I don't believe in global warming,
but I do believe in a greenhouse effect.
'Cause I believe we live
in a greenhouse, you know?
And I do think that how we
treat this place we live
in is very critical to the
quality of life and other lives
and not just us, all the
different ecosystems and things.
So I'm also a vegan.
I know, that's.
- Nice.
- Yeah, so I try to do no harm, you know?
- Do you believe in any
other uncommon beliefs?
- Yeah, definitely.
I believe in giants.
That there was a race
of humans that were very, very, very tall.
- That's interesting.
I kind of agree with you.
- Really?
- I'm not gonna lie.
Yes, it makes sense 'cause
dinosaurs like they were so huge.
So what makes you think
that humans couldn't have
evolved that way either?
- Totally
- Yeah.
- How has your idea
of the earth being flat
affected your relationships?
- I've lost family members
who want nothing to do
with me because of my belief.
When I first came into flat earth,
I absolutely came in to try to refute it.
I went into this belief
kicking and screaming.
I never ever ever thought
I would be a flat earthers.
- I'm curious what your
dating life is like.
- I will say I only date flat earthers.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- Have you ever dated anyone
with a differing opinion?
I was married, so I lost my husband.
He was killed and so I've
just, that was about 2010.
So I didn't really come
into the flat earth
until around 2015, 2016
where I really started questioning it.
- Do you have any kids?
- I do, yes.
I have two children.
My daughter who is 19 and I
have a son who will be 14.
- Do they agree with
the flat earth theory?
- I will say that I've given my children
the opportunity to learn both.
My daughter really doesn't care.
She's like, don't talk about it mom.
I don't really care, you know?
So I try not to embarrass
her when she'll see stuff
like this and my son is
definitely a flat earth.
- What is your favorite
thing about the earth?
- My favorite thing about the earth
is that despite anybody's
idea of what shape it is,
we're all here for a purpose.
And the relationships that we make here
are the most precious things.
The beauty in being alive here.
- That's beautiful.
- Thank you.
- Do you think we could be more tolerant
of radical opinions?
- I think so.
I think it's important
for us to be able to stand
in our truth and
understand and have empathy
of where people are at and
why maybe they feel that way.
And I may lose everything in everybody,
but I'm gonna still stand.
And thankfully we live
in a country where we're
able to express openly
or hopefully we can,
ideas that aren't popular,
and being able to stand
in that truth is really what's
at the heart of the matter.
- Okay.
- Hi.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for sharing.
- You're so sweet.
- Information to me.
- I loved all the questions.
- Thank you for answering.
- Oh she had a nicer mic than me.
- [Speaker] Parents are heroes.
Right, you're right.